It's become the main attraction in this sleepy town southwest of Tokyo,...
...a high-speed rail so fast, blink and you'll miss it.
Onboard, the Superconducting or SCMaglev can top 370 miles an hour,...
...making it the fastest train in the world.
How is this able to reach speeds of up to 375 miles an hour?
How we do that is, we levitate the train ten centimeters above ground using magnetic force.
These powerful magnets and ground coils interact to accelerate speeds,...
...literally lifting the train off the tracks.
It almost feels like a plane taking off,...
...and the Central Japan Railway Company or JRC says it's nearly as fast,...
...the train expected to make the 215-mile journey from Tokyo to Nagoya in 40 minutes.